foreign
as we all know well most of us know by
now uh President Biden has been
attempting to forgive ten thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt 20 if
you're a Pell Grant recipient and uh so
far has not been able to pull off that
idea
in two years
um the latest version is that the uh
that it was that the whole idea of him
being able to forgive debt was not legal
and so it was taken to court
and uh so it's in court and they've been
kicked all the way up to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court has agreed
to hear it uh in February and it comes
out today that will be February 28th
of course our Judicial System always to
picking the last possible day to do
anything so they're going to put it off
as far as they possibly can
um slower than Christmas oh wait a
minute Christmas is already here yeah
okay that came up fast so uh
so a number of conservative backed
lawsuits arose seeking to block the
relief and two have the two of them have
temporarily succeeded thus far one
lawsuit filed by Six republican-led
States argued that relief would hurt
their State's tax revenues and that of
missouri-based student loan company uh
the other lawsuit was filed by two
student loan borrowers who sued because
they did not qualify for the full twenty
thousand dollars of relief
oh okay and
uh two lower courts that received each
of those cases ruled the Biden's loan
forgiveness plan should remain on pause
until the Supreme Court makes a final
decision on the legality of the relief
and now it has gone to a supreme court
of course in the Supreme Court today
comes out and says we will um
I will be taking on both lawsuits The
Challenge on February the 28th
you know I can't I don't know what
taking on means
does that mean they're going to rule on
that day or they're going to start the
process of hearings on that day that was
going to be gonna be a question because
my first thought is woohoo
finally we haven't
said that over and over again where I'm
like okay we have a date we have a date
for when the pause ends we have a date
when people will know exactly what to do
next and then we don't have dates that
are somebody's foot is sore from kicking
the can so much right yeah you think so
it's like is the 28th the date you think
that they're going to rule on it or is
it just going to officially start a long
time they're taking it this is Yahoo for
you but I mean
the nation's highest court announcer
will be taking on both lawsuits the
challenge we knew that I just saw
another article that says they were
they'll hear hear oral arguments that
day okay so they're going to begin the
process that day so six or eight more
months
maybe if we're lucky or you're lucky or
you're not lucky here's the thing
um we told you when this first came up
that before it came up that it was going
to come up
uh we told you what was going to happen
um and uh We've we've predicted every
step of the way on this and all along
the way have been telling you to pay
your student loans exactly just because
the government is kicking the can down
the road does not mean your life should
be put on hold right you need to clear
your life get victory over this area of
your life and move on with your life you
sit around wait on the government to fix
your life your life's always going to
suck
so you can't do that you've got to lean
into this and you got to say this is my
deal I signed up for these loans I'm
going to pay them now right and it's
just going to be much better for you if
you've got the loans
um I'll feel dumb if the government
comes no you won't you'll feel proud
that you actually honored your
obligation
that's not dumb yeah I've seen so many
people in my Instagram DMS just cheering
that they paid it off even with the the
carrot dangling of forgiveness they're
still proud of themselves for having
paid off those loans so it's like if you
do not like that anxiety if you don't
like that feeling of being at the whim
of a government and the student loan
forgiveness pay off your loans like just
get it done yeah you don't have to stay
in this space of unknown a Perpetual I
promise you someday oh by a politician
by a court system
it's going to be forever it's going to
be forever don't wait on forever don't
don't please don't wait any more payoff
now